as this white-bellied sea eagle feeds
its young near borneo another eagle
appears an intruder a threat a menace to
the family safety it's time for a major
turf battle first a simple warning
doesn't work the home team does some
reconnaissance things go from bad to
worse the habitat crasher now blatantly
rips off a fish - huh he wants a fight
the female means to give him one the two
Eagles get in a midair tug-of-war she's
just taking his measure the real battle
is about to begin the two males square
off like World War one fighter pilots
the Eagles climb and climb each trying
to get a height advantage on the other
they come in each other and lock talons
and begin a helicoptering the scent
called whirling this time they break it
off but they're not done with each other
yet
this whirligig is to see who stays and
who goes like a crazy game of chicken
the whirling Eagles plummet toward the
earth each daring the other to be the
first to unlock talents both hold on
until
the intruder acknowledges his defeat
time to move on
the home team celebrates the victory
with a triumphant glide over there now
secure home turf